an important clinical trial of the drug
hydro hydro chloric Wynne is on hold
because of concerns that it may be
harmful to some patients the president
says he took the drug to fight off the
corona virus our dr. David agus joins us
David good morning the world hell why
did the World Health Organization take
this this step right now
good morning Anthony and you know this
is a trial called the Solidarity trial
400 hospitals 35 country several
thousand patients already being treated
into one of five groups the first group
is whatever the hospital normally cares
were no direct copa 19 medications the
second is REM disappear the drug that
recently show benefit the third is an
HIV combination the fourth is the HIV
combination with beta interferon a
multiple sclerosis drug and the fifth is
hydroxychloroquine so what they said now
is that even though they've had regular
safety tracks and there has been no
indication of increased complications
with hydroxyl cleric and they're gonna
stop enrolling for about a week the
hydroxychloroquine arm only and take a
closer look given the results that were
published in Lancet last week at a
Columbia University make sense make sure
that there's no side effects that were
missed
David the whao also expressed concerns
about the possibility of a second peak
if social distancing guidelines are
eased too quickly what are the real
concerns about a second peak well we're
having small peaks across the country in
different areas at the present time and
we will continue to do so across the
country the hope is they don't continue
to gain and then we actually go toward a
wave I think that's what we all are
afraid of so we know how to prevent them
very simply social distancing wearing a
mask are critical and so as we open up
and more people go to work and go to
their you know out we need to practice
the simple things that have been shown
to work to prevent this virus David as
we've been reporting this morning
wearing a mask is becoming somewhat
politicized dr. deborah birx said as you
just did that it's critical why is it so
important
well when you and I speak and we breathe
droplets come out of our mouth and this
virus is transmitted predominantly
through droplets so if those droplets
are blocked by a mask then we will have
dramatically less transmission of the
virus you need a significant amount of
virus to transmit it and just by
blocking with a mask reduces it enough
that we can really block transmission in
this country if everyone wore a mask
we would be much safer going forward and
much less chance of having a second peak
alright dr. David agus thank you David